para nebras de 26 años febrero ha
marcado un giro para los tunecinos
afrodescendientes acaba de graduarse de
la universidad y trabaja como camarera
cree que La retórica anti inmigrante del
presidente
ha dado luz verde al racismo
hay gente que me preguntaba qué hacía yo
aquí todavía
estaba matando gente algunos me pararon
en medio de la calle y me dijeron que me
fuera que me fuera
el mes pasado scient lanzó una campaña
contra los inmigrantes subsaharianos en
túnez afirmó que estaban detrás de la
mayor parte de la delincuencia del país
y que existía un complot criminal para
cambiar la demografía de túnez los
tunecinos afrodescendientes son
Realmente víctimas colaterales del
discurso del presidente porque el
discurso no iba dirigido a la piel negra
estaba dirigido a los inmigrantes Pero
obviamente son Víctimas colaterales de
este discurso los comentarios han
desencadenado una oleada de ataques y
desalojos cientos de africanos
occidentales incluso han regresado a su
país de origen por miedo a ser objeto de
ataques sadia ha ayudado a cubrir las
necesidades de los más vulnerables pero
también le preocupa que los tunecinos
afrodescendientes sean los siguientes
somos una población visible y
estigmatizada hoy el miedo Es que seamos
el objetivo porque el primer paso son
los subsaharianos el miedo Es que el
segundo paso sea los tunecinos
afrodescendientes
[Música]
Los tunecinos afrodescendientes
representan entre el 10 y el 15% de los
12 millones de habitantes del país el
presidente ha rechazado las acusaciones
de que está avivando el racismo
afirmando que sus comentarios fueron mal
interpretados por sus oponentes